[Music]
[Music]
majira's mask will forever remain
a fascinating anomaly to me a good
analogy for this game would be that
majira's mask
as a sequel to ocarina of time is like
making a big hollywood blockbuster
and following it up with a low budget in
the art house film
on paper this game should not be as good
as it turned out to be
limited development time of only a year
and recycling assets aside
its themes in the overall atmosphere are
such a monumental contrast to ocarina of
time
it almost feels as if a completely
different studio got their hands on the
zelda ip and decided to do something
weird and experimental with it
yeah like that only not bad
it has been more than 20 years and this
game still stands tall atop my list of
favorite games of all time
and yet i've never made a single video
about it ever since i started my channel
but that is about to change so hold on
to your seats because i'm about to
explain the nature of majora its
whereabouts in the timeline
possible return and how this all
ultimately ties into its appearance in
breath of the wild
so let's get started
majira's mask is described as an
accursed item from ancient legends
said to have been used in hexing rituals
by an ancient tribe
the mayhem it caused reached the point
that the tribe itself
started fearing it to avoid catastrophe
the mask was sealed in darkness by the
ancient ones to prevent further misuse
this mystery tribe spoken of in legends
eventually vanished into thin air
and no one alive today knows about the
mask's true power
there is a lot of mystery surrounding
majora as the game itself doesn't reveal
much about its nature
its origin or even how it resurfaced
after all this time
there are plenty of great theories out
there but nothing is conclusive and
given nintendo's habit of making us fill
in the blanks it likely never will be
what is clear is that the mask itself is
not the true source of evil
it's just a piece of decorated wood and
nothing more
instead the real evil originates from
the entity that dwells inside it only
known as majora
it is made obvious that this evil has
left the mask at the end of the game
having been defeated at the hands of
link the mask was reduced to a mere
shell of wood and fiber as it likely
once was before majora housed itself
inside
all seems well until you realize that oh
yeah
the zelda timeline isn't straightforward
now is it
the events of majira's mask are but one
of three possible outcomes
so what about the other two timelines
what fate befell termina and its people
in those
realities since we're dealing with time
travel and alternate realities it can
get confusing real quick so i'll try to
sum it up as briefly as i can
the entire premise of majora's mask and
its outcome is entirely made possible
due to four different variables
link the happy mask salesman skull kid
and
timing i firmly believe that the
salesman and skull kid are alive at the
beginning of all three timelines
the child timeline speaks for itself as
that is where majora's mask takes place
kid is practically immortal as he is
classified as a spirit
not only that but he is featured in the
ancient stories of termina so he already
visited termina a long time ago and
would likely travel back there again in
the future
the mask salesman is seen at the
celebration during ocarina of times
credits which takes place at the
beginning of the adult timeline and in
the downfall timeline we find an
incarnation of him
possibly a descendant who has set up
shop in labrena this leads me to believe
that he has also survived this outcome
and one additional reason which i will
mention later
the only one who isn't around in the
other timelines is the hero of time but
even if he was it would still be
unlikely that the events of majora would
have occurred
sure the masked salesman could have
potentially traveled to termina
somewhere in between link's child and
adult adventure while link was trapped
inside the sacred realm only to travel
back to hyrule in time for the
celebration at the end
even then it still would have been
highly unlikely that things would have
aligned the exact same way
the key which brings it all together is
timing in order for the events of
majira's mask to play out like it did
all three individuals would have to be
in the exact right place
at exactly the right time i think it's
safe to say that the happy mask salesman
was already on his way back to hyrule
when he was ambushed by the skull kid
since he could never have been in the
possession of the mask if he was still
on his way to termina in turn the skull
kid too would have to be in the lost
woods at that exact moment in order to
run into the salesman
we can see in some of the cutscenes that
skull kid spends a lot of time just
messing around in termina with his
newfound fairy companions
so it's not like he's always hanging
around in the lost woods had the
salesman arrived in termina one day
earlier or later the two may have never
even run into each other
a majora's mask with the evil still
inside would have been taken to hyrule
or wherever else the masked salesman was
heading next and lastly link
also would have to arrive at the right
moment in order to get caught up in the
events which ultimately leads him to
defeating majora and ridding the mask of
the evil presence
and this incarnation of link aka the
hero of time would have also been the
only hero to be able to defeat majora
as without the ocarina of time this task
would have been impossible
this begs the question since link never
traveled to termina in the adult and
downfall timeline does this mean termini
has been annihilated by the moon
in those realities i mean link wasn't
around to stop it right
well no probably not because as we just
illustrated the timing is
very delicate one single change in the
schedule of the mask salesman or that of
skull kid
would already be enough to completely
throw the alignments off so you see when
it comes to the fate of termina
it's actually not that relevant whether
or not the masked salesman did or did
not travel to termina in the other two
timelines
if he did then he could have
successfully taken the mask from termina
and brought it somewhere else without
running into trouble along the way
if he did not then the mask would have
remained in termina but it would have
never found its way into the hands of
skull kid since he took the mask from
the salesman not to mention that if the
masked salesman was the one who
originally broke the seal on majora it
would still to this day be sealed in
darkness somewhere perhaps for all
eternity
either way in both cases the evil would
still be inside the mask
but let's say he did let's say that no
matter the outcome in hyrule
at some point in time the happy mask
salesman will travel to termina to
search for the mask
given his obsession with rare masks
there is a big chance that he was
already aware of the legends surrounding
majora even when he was still in hyrule
and was always planning
to look for it someday the only thing
that differs is when he set off on his
quest
this could mean that in the other two
timelines the mask salesman never ran
into the skull kit because the timing of
events would have been so radically
different
and thus he managed to successfully get
the mask out of termina this would
explain the presence of the mask in a
link between worlds
without writing it off as a simple
easter egg a link between worlds also
happens to take place in the downfall
timeline
the only timeline aside from the child
branch where we find an incarnation of
the happy masked salesman i'm not going
to get into how the mask ultimately made
its way onto a wall in link's house
as that is a theory on its own but
hypothetically speaking
let's say that this is the real deal the
real majira's mask
and in the adult timeline the mask also
made its way into hyrule or some other
place outside termina at some point by
that definition the mask we find in
those timelines would still have the
evil entity inside it since the skull
kid never stole it and the hero of time
is non-existent and thus never faced
majora to begin with
if this is the case how come we don't
see moons crashing towards earth
chaos and armageddon why is hyrule
spared this fate altogether
in order to answer this question we need
to do some theorizing about majora as an
entity
and how its powers operate
the true origin of majora's mask where
it was sealed and who this mysterious
tribe was who used it are unknown
we also have no definitive answer as to
how the masked salesman came into its
possession in the first place
if he was the one who broke the seal on
the mask or if someone else did and the
salesman simply made a deal for it but
the fact that he states that he went
through great lengths to acquire it
hints that he might be the one who took
it from its seal
the only thing we can find in the game
related to majora's backstory is a
secret shrine in akana canyon
this place is filled with imagery
related to the mask and could very well
be the place where the rituals spoken of
in the ancient legends took place
but if this is also where the mask was
found and by who remains up in the air
there exist countless theories about it
and perhaps i will make a video about it
someday as i do have some ideas but
these are topics for another time what
we want to focus on is not necessarily
the mask itself but rather the entity
that dwells within
majora is described as more than just a
faceless evil hellbound on causing
destruction
it has all the traits of that of a deity
somehow bound to a physical object
the four giants link encounters in the
game are classified as guardian deities
and are sealed inside a mask-like object
by majora
additionally we have the fierce deity
mask which as the name suggests is set
to house an
unknown yet powerful deity so it's only
natural to assume that the same
characteristics of a deity trapped or
bound to a mask
also applies to majora it may seem
trivial but there is a good reason why
this matters
we know that the zelda team has derived
a lot of their ideas and symbolism from
shintoism by far the biggest religion in
japan with almost 80 percent of its
population putting its customs into
practice to some degree
the shinto religion is well known for
the worship of a wide array of spirits
guardian deities and gods known as kami
the aspects of kami are
very complicated as there's many
different types subgroups and all with
different traits
names and various degrees of power and
importance even the word kami can
already mean different things depending
on the context but to oversimplify
kami can be elements of the landscape
forces of nature as well as beings and
the qualities that these beings express
more importantly kami are not inherently
good or evil
as shintoism makes no distinction
between the two generally speaking they
can be nurturing and comforting when
respected
or become vengeful and destructive when
neglected
shinto followers also believe that the
kami are the ones who can either grant
blessings or
curses to a person as such they desire
to appease the kami to
quote stay on their good side kami must
be appeased in order to gain their favor
and avoid their wrath and failing to do
so can lead to catastrophic events
commonly in the form of natural
disasters
dying crops or curses in order to avoid
this the shinto practice sees a wide
array of rituals
revolving around appeasing these deities
even demons which are called oni
and kami are generally regarded as the
same thing
and they too can either bring blessings
or curses the fine line separating
demons and gods is further evident from
the fierce deity mask
an english link while wearing the mask
is mostly referred to as simply
fierce deity link however in japanese
his name is kishin rinku
kishin being a japanese word made up of
the characters ogre
and god and commonly translates to
fierce god
or wrathful deity with this information
in mind let's take a closer look at
majora according to the legend majira's
mask was involved
in all sorts of ominous rituals by an
ancient tribe until finally being
quote sealed in darkness out of fear of
misuse
this seems to suggest that majora was
always inherently evil and caused
so much trouble that the ancient ones
decided to rid themselves
of the mask but what if it was the other
way around what if just like the kami
majora was just an entity neither good
nor evil
the tribe are the ones responsible for
using its power for its own benefit
the quote trouble caused by majora
spoken of in the legends
may not have been its own doing but
rather one or more members of the tribe
who used it for malicious intent
then to prevent further misuse by some
of the tribe's members the mask was
sealed away or hidden in a dark place
somewhere
again kami are not good or evil a deity
simply acts upon that which his
worshippers feed into
what if the reason why majora turned
vengeful was not because of the rituals
but because the rituals
stopped majora's evil nature may be the
result of neglect
after hiding the mask away from the rest
of the world the ancient tribe who used
its power
disappeared for unknown reasons sealed
in darkness
forgotten and abandoned by its
worshippers the entity inside the mask
slowly turned
vengeful and by the time the mask is
rediscovered it releases its anger upon
the world without mercy
as soon as it latches itself onto skull
kid it starts turning nature against the
population of termina
poisoned waters endless winters polluted
seas and cursed lands and finally
armageddon we even see this motif of
what it means to be good or evil
reflected back onto the final act of the
game some of the lunar children found on
the moon right before the final boss
fight hint at this
uncertainty saying things like the right
thing
what is it i wonder if you do the right
thing
does it really make everybody happy
or let's play good guys and bad guys
i'll be the good guy
and you'll be the bad guy essentially
doing a role reversal and placing link
in the shoes of the bad guy
even though he has done nothing but to
help the people of termina
and ridding the land of majora's curses
and during the boss fight itself we see
the three stages of majora through its
different forms
it starts with just a mask nothing more
than an object
then comes majora's incarnation the
entity inside the mask
this form of majora is playful energetic
a bit
silly even if it wasn't part of the boss
fight i'd say it doesn't really look all
that malicious
but then finally we transitioned to the
final stage majora's wrath
the hate which had festered and built up
inside the deity for being neglected and
forgotten
finally breaks free longing for revenge
on the world around it
there is one final aspect i want to
cover about majora and one which will
make it more apparent where i'm going
with all this
another trait of the shinto kami is that
in some cases they are bound to a
specific group of people
location or element in a sense they have
boundaries or domains from which they
operate or exercise their influence
they are also not considered omnipotent
or even immortal
kami can in fact die and there are many
examples of this happening in shinto
legend
the locations where these kami are set
to reside are often indicated by what's
called a torii gate a man-made archway
meant to communicate that you are now
entering the domain
so to speak of a specific kami it also
often leads to a shrine devoted to said
deity
as such i firmly believe that majora's
power is either non-existent or at the
very least severely diminished outside
the borders of termina
and there are several indications of
this first is the fact that skull kid is
able to take the mask off when he's
inside the lost woods
something he never does once he is in
termina this indicates that skull kid
still has control over himself when he
resides in hyrule
it's apparent that skull kid likes to
mess with people the act of ambushing
the mask salesman is something he does
without the mask and seemingly on his
own volition the same thing goes for
stealing link's horse and ocarina you
can clearly see from his body language
and silly demeanor that this is still
skull kid behind the wheel
his actions although rude are not
necessarily evil
not only that but despite link's attempt
to lash out at him and take back his
ocarina
skull kid never attempts to fight back
instead resorting to a game of chase
but as soon as link falls down the hole
and enters the boundaries of termina
skull kid immediately uses the mask's
power to cast a curse on link
almost as if he was waiting to strike as
soon as link ventured into its domain
his tone and demeanor also promptly
shifting from that of a dimwitted
prankster to
outright militias from this moment on we
never see skull kid take off the mask
until the moment at the very end where
madura states that his puppet has
fulfilled its role
this could indicate that when the mask
resides in hyrule for instance
its powers are negligible at best since
majora is a deity belonging to the land
of termina
which finally brings us to breath of the
wild the fact that majora's mask shows
up as a usable quest item and not just a
little reference hanging on a wall
somewhere is
already quite interesting i do believe
that the inclusion of the mask
is canon something i already covered in
my video about misco the great bandit
in that video i suggested that all items
related to the misco dlc
are likely canon they were part of a
series of ancient artifacts holding
historical value which the royal family
had collected over the many years until
misko broke into the castle and stole
them away
i also made the case that some of these
have to be replicas and not the real
deal
as some of these items or apparel were
either destroyed or banished or
in other words couldn't possibly have
made their way into the game in their
original form what i didn't mention in
that video was that the description of
some of these items
actually seems to confirm this just look
at the way some of these items are
described the phantom armor
this helmet looks like the one day
referring to the armored phantoms
supposedly wore
mitna's helmet a helmet much like the
one mitna wore when she fought alongside
the hero of twilight
the wording here such as looks just like
and much like definitely suggests that
they are not the original
now let's take a look at the description
for majora's mask an airy mask
passed down from ancient times nowhere
does it seem to hint that it's a replica
in fact the opposite is true
it states that it has been passed down
from ancient times you
cannot pass something down from ancient
times if it's not the real deal
so assuming that this is indeed the real
mask
the million dollar question then remains
which timeline does it originate from
is it the harmless version from the
child timeline after the evil has left
the mask
or is it from one of the other two where
majora's evil presence
is potentially still inside it we
definitely see that the mask
still has power since it's able to fool
undead style enemies
the eyes also still glow how is that
possible if majora was no longer inside
it
wouldn't it be just a piece of wood and
nothing more if this is the real version
of the mask one where madura is still
inside
it should still be mostly harmless since
as stated before
it likely has no power here however if
someone would be stupid enough to bring
the mask back to termina someday
god help us all
thank you for watching and a big thanks
to my amazing patreons and members
of which mr nucleosome and fertzaner
just joined as my latest supporters
you guys are awesome thanks a lot anyway
i will hopefully see you all soon in the
next video
this is dawn signing off and have a
good one
[Music]
hey
[Music]
you